to like learn together and have those
conversations if you're each other's
only sexual partner
yeah i mean i would think so like
i feel like you can
oh my gosh i don't want to like say it
but i feel like you can like tell
someone what you like and what you don't
like you know
if it's your first sexual experience how
do you know what you like
i don't know
i feel like
i feel like you know on some level
no i'd say
it took me a while to find out what i do
and don't like
oh god
[Music]
he is being careful with the how he
speaks because he's talking to a woman
he doesn't want to ruffle your feathers
i have no filter i'm just being careful
out of respect for my ex and there's a
lot yeah that doesn't need to be out
there yeah yeah
um
have you watched the tinder swandler
no
but i am planning on watching it with
someone
yeah
do you know what happened
i've seen it around on social media sort
of yeah has that been your experience on
tinder
i don't think i've seen enough to know
what you mean by that oh no he like um
got
basically like free stuff you got girls
to take out hundreds of thousands of
dollars in loans
yeah i've not experienced that i'm not
giving anyone money without knowing that
no they give him the girls gave him
money i'm not going out looking for
money
and i'm a student and poor but you know
oh my gosh
well
i appreciate you coming on is there
anything else you want to talk about on
the podcast on the podcast
yeah um
you i watched
the last one earlier today okay i'm
trying to think what tickled me
what tickled you yeah it grubbed you the
wrong way
was it me did i say something what did i
say
i'm opinionated so i wouldn't be shocked
what did you go through
it was about
toxicity wasn't it oh that was right
that one toxic are we attracted to toxic
relationships
like
i wouldn't say men
look for a toxic relationship
but i'd say
the most toxic women are the typical
mean girls
type of women which is what a man wants
so that's what they end up with
wait so you think men are attracted to
toxic women
yeah okay
elaborate
they're not attracted to the toxicity
okay
this it seems a typical toxic woman is
a pretty girl gets her nails done la la
la okay yeah i'd agree obviously
that's what a guy wants they want a
pretty girl who looks after herself yeah
yeah so they just end up with that toxic
girl
okay
it's not necessarily they're not looking
for the so you think it's like because
they're hot basically the hot girls are
the toxic ones yeah okay
yeah i could see that for sure
because i feel like there's pretty
privilege you know
so the more attractive you are like the
more people kind of give you the benefit
of the doubt yeah and they get attention
yeah and so with that it's like
like girls always say the best guys are
the former fat ones
because they became funny to get girls
i mean
i was fat and i wouldn't say i'm funny
you're a little funny on the you had a
funny answer when i interviewed you the
other day
that that i've seen that back the answer
doesn't even make sense to me now
i thought it was the best one actually
because i so i asked him
what's the difference between a woman
showing
that she's what did i say it was like
what's the difference between a woman
um playing hard to get and actually
being interested
i said something about them in bed no
you said like it's how quick they get
into bed yeah something like that yeah
which is kind of like kind of true
she puts her money where her mouth is
she's actually interested
right
yes
but what i've learned through talking to
people recently is no
no
no okay elaborate
there are some girls who
want to get to know you they're not
being hard to get but it's just
their way of wanting to get into a real
relationship that they aren't just going
to jump straight into bed yeah no that's
true
because
well and i think women are more
risk-averse
well yeah there's a lot of risks yeah
women having sex yeah more than like a
guy yeah yeah
but no that was kind of funny i
i was like i hope he's not mad i posted
that clip yeah i don't mind just fine i
remember waking up in the middle of the
night and seeing it
oh god it's up there
no it's fine it's in a youtube video i
made
so
um you think so back to the toxic
relationships do you
think
like men are addicted to the toxicity or
do you think men tend to leave because
i think women
get kind of addicted to it
like i think we finding toxic men yeah
oh for sure like you hear the girls on
the show
yeah yeah one of them had a few toxic
relationships yeah no um and uh like
something becomes addicting about it but
then
on the show
i mean she's a lovely girl but you had
gaby and she said she's been the cause
of the toxic relationship she's been the
toxic one oh yeah yeah
pretty girl with a nice body and stuff
like that so
that's what guys go for not because she
is toxic but because she's got that
figure and attraction that guys want
well i think that in like any toxic
relationship like you have to admit like
it takes two to tango
right so both people in a toxic
relationship are toxic
to some extent yeah
i think you either like especially if
you allow it like i've definitely
allowed [ __ ] that like
wasn't okay but i like i'm not gonna sit
here and cry me a river when i stayed
you know what i mean
okay would you class this as toxic okay
so
i met my ex in
summer
20
let's say fifth no no no earlier 13
something like that
we got together we got to know each
other blah blah blah
she wasn't interested in me
i then got of another girl
i then met up with my ex again
and
we tried it again
and i left this other girl immediately
for her
oh okay is that toxic
or is that i don't know
i i broke that of a girl's heart
um i wouldn't say it's toxic i would say
like toxic to me is
if you did you use that girl to get make
the other girl jealous i'd say that
would be toxic
but i wouldn't say that i wouldn't say
that was my intentions but that's what
happened yeah well
i would say um it's more like the toxic
no i think she was just your second
choice it sucks but
yeah she was yeah like
most people it's happened to at some
point you can't be everyone's first
choice sometimes you get bamboozled
yeah like
so i would just say she took an owl
okay
but i wouldn't say i would say toxic is
like
lying like
um i'd say lying is mostly toxic like
not taught like
i don't want to like give too much
[Music]
i don't know mostly like lying i would
say is toxic behavior or
you know what's it called when like
gaslighting or like when they switch it
and like put it on you when they're like
guilty about something super jealous
like crazy stuff
i don't
yeah that's what i think of
let's see i don't i don't think thank
you for the five dollar super chat black
ops
i appreciate you it's going towards the
sound board okay
i don't think men are not attracted to
toxic women but they are attracted to
attractive women no man seeks out toxic
women sam is the goat
why why why am i go because you were
they like them
they like the men that can like juggle
the women
you know what i mean like because a lot
of my audience is men it's like 80 men
20 women something like that
so
they my audience likes guys that can
like get girls
like i think they admire it so you're go
because you get the two
because
some guys can't get one